pourtant c'est quand je connais le
fonctionnement
bonjour merci beaucoup de votre présence
mais chers collègues fidèles aux
auditions
madame la rapporteur nous poursuivons et
puis mesdames et messieurs Olivier
Jacques qui nous a accompagnés
toute l'équipe qui nous accompagne
depuis le début de cette commission
d'enquête donc tout poursuivons cet
après-midi les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par l'audition donc
de Monsieur Reda guia président de
pfizer france je vous remercie monsieur
le Président de vous être mobilisé pour
cette audition vous êtes accompagné par
Monsieur Franck le breguero pharmacien
responsable et Madame Catherine Raymond
directrice des affaires publiques
alors que Pfizer figure depuis longtemps
parmi les leaders mondiaux du secteur
pharmaceutique son chiffre d'affaires a
encore d'oublier ces dernières années
pour dépasser en 2022 les 100 milliards
de dollars cette hausse aussi soudaine
que spectaculaire est dû pour
l'essentiel au développement et à la
commercialisation quelques mois d'un
vaccin contre l'épidémie de covid 19 qui
a représenté à lui seul en Europe la
majorité des injections réalisées
si ce formidable succès industriel a
fini d'assurer la notoriété
internationale de Pfizer il a également
alimenté un certain nombre de polémiques
ces derniers mois celle-ci ont notamment
visé l'opacité des contrats conclus avec
la Commission européenne pour la
fourniture de vaccins nous vous
interrogerons sur les enjeux d'une plus
grande transparence des prix des
médicaments demandés de longue date par
certaines associations mais aussi par
certains états enfin et alors que notre
commission d'enquête a pour objectif de
rechercher les causes des phénomènes de
pénurie et leurs liens avec les choix
opérés par les industriels nous
souhaitons que votre audition soit
l'occasion de nous éclairer sur la
manière dont une entreprise comme la
vôtre organise et évalue ces chaînes
d'approvisionnement ainsi que ces stocks
plus spécialement nous souhaiterions
mesurer les actions entreprises par
Pfizer pour s'assurer de la
disponibilité de ces produits en France
et le cas échéant y investir dans ses
capacités de production
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets monsieur le
Président je vais vous céder la parole
pour un bref propos introductif puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre mission de commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions comme vous l'aurez compris
notre commission d'enquête en temps
obtenir des réponses étayées à des
questions précises et sur un sujet qui
dure déjà depuis un certain nombre
d'années et qui va en s'aggravant je
précise également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 434-14 et 434-15 du
code pénal et je vous invite maintenant
chacun à votre tour à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant l'anime main droite en disant
je le jure
donc monsieur le président
monsieur lebrigero
madame Raynaud
je vous remercie donc je vous laisse la
parole
oui
merci merci
très bien alors
madame la présidente madame le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité à m'exprimer devant votre
commission d'enquête à propos d'un sujet
qui est particulièrement important les
pénuries des médicaments alors tous les
intervenants que vous avez auditionné
l'ont souligner ce phénomène est
complexe et multi factorielle il
constitue une préoccupation majeure pour
faizer comme pour l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de notre système de santé
notre intérêt commun est de faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de pénurie
alors à titre personnel et en tant que
pharmacien cette question me tient
particulièrement à cœur
avant toute chose laissez-moi vous
décrire en quelques mots notre
portefeuille de produit en France
Pfizer exploite en France 120
médicaments et vaccins ce qui correspond
à 350 et une présentation et environ 90%
de ces produits sont des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur c'est à
dire les amis
tous ces amis thèmes font l'objet comme
la loi le prévoit de plantes gestion des
pénuries PGP qui sont communiqués à NSM
nous suivons également avec attention
nos autres produits qui ne rentrent pas
dans cette catégorie
nos médicaments permettent de traiter un
grand nombre de pathologies dont des
arts thérapeutiques aussi différentes
que l'immunologie le l'oncologie la
virologie les vaccins les maladies rares
et la médecine interne
en termes de produits en cours de
développement
notre pipeline comprend à ce jour 110
programmes de recherche dans 23
programmes en phase 3 et 16 programmes
en phase d'enregistrement
près de 9000 patients français étaient
inclus en 2021 dans nos essais cliniques
en France
alors en termes de production
Pfizer dispose de 36 sites de
fabrication en propre localisé en Europe
en Amérique du Nord
Amérique du Sud Afrique du Nord
Moyen-Orient
Océanie et Asie
notre chaîne d'approvisionnement et de
production comprend également plus de
315 sites externes répartis dans 44 pays
dont 14 pays européens
alors un point très important maintenant
notre entreprise est très peu dépendante
de la Chine et de l'Inde et je
souhaiterais souligné ce point même si
notre même si nous disposons
d'infrastructures importantes dans ces
deux pays les trois quarts de la
production de médicaments réalisés en
Chine et en Inde sont destinés à
l'approvisionnement des marchés chinois
et indiens
la production en provenance de Chine et
d'Inde ne représente pas plus de 0
points 6% de nos médicaments distribués
en France 0.6%
d'ailleurs
98% de nos médicaments distribués en
France sont fabriqués en Europe
dernier point de contexte nous mettons à
la disposition des patients des
médicaments très innovants comme des
produits ça va des produits matures des
médicaments chimiques comme biologiques
des anticoramonoclonaux comme des
vaccins des médicaments biocellulaires
combien taux des médicaments de thérapie
génique
vous comprenez donc que ce portefeuille
est très diversifié et que tous nos
médicaments ne font pas face au même
enjeux
alors comment appréhendons-nous le sujet
des pénuries de médicaments tout d'abord
les pénuries ne concernent pas que la
France il s'agit d'un phénomène global
dans les causes peuvent être nombreuses
et bien sûr très variables
il peut tout d'abord s'agir de cause
dites externe alors je pense notamment à
une augmentation brutale et imprévisible
de la demande concernant certains
produits nous avons vécu cette situation
au début de la crise du covid-19 avec
l'écureur qui sont des médicaments
utilisés
en anesthésie et en réanimation la
demande au tout début d'ailleurs la
demande a été multipliée par près de 4
en seulement quelques jours
et nous avons eu nous avons su faire
face et puis les deux semaines suivantes
nous avons dû fournir l'équivalent de 5
mois de stock 5 - 2 stock ce qui est
considérable
sur le seul mois de mars 2020 nous avons
fourni l'équivalent de 8 mois de stock
externes peuvent également prévenir
provenir d'une situation de tension ou
de rupture affectant une entreprise
concurrente nous devons alors répondre à
cette situation en fournissant des
volumes qui ne sont pas initialement
destinés à approvisionner une telle part
de marché
ces différents situations peuvent aussi
être amplifiées par la pratique
d'exportation parallèle par certains
grossistes
alors je passe maintenant à des causes
internes il peut aussi en Suisse s'agir
de cause interne plusieurs facteurs
rentrent en jeu par exemple des retards
liés à des problèmes industriels
affectant des fournisseurs il peut
s'agir de matière première d'excipion ou
d'articles de conditionnement la chaîne
de production et d'approvisionnement du
médicament est un processus complexe qui
mobilise de nombreux acteurs
d'autres causes internes sont liées à
des investigations en matière de qualité
et ça c'est un point très important et
cela est un point vraiment fondamental
tout nos médicaments sans exception sont
soumis à des processus de qualité
particulièrement strictes et j'y suis
très attaché en matière de sécurité je
vais être très clair
99% de certitudes n'est pas acceptable
chez Pfizer c'est 100% ou rien
un autre point très important par
rapport aux causes des pénuries de
médicaments c'est qu'elles sont toutes
dans la grande majorité des cas
indépendantes des décisions prises par
les entreprises pharmaceutiques et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous travaillons
en main dans la main avec le
gouvernement avec les autorités et
notamment avec la NSM afin de prévenir
les situations de rupture
nos équipes échangent quasi
quotidiennement avec la NSM et je
voudrais vous dire que les équipes de
l'agence on charge de ces sujets sont
particulièrement à l'écoute réactive et
Dante
malgré tous nos efforts Fighter connaît
malheureusement certains situations de
tension ou de rupture en 2022 faizara a
adressé 123 notifications de risque de
rupture ou de rupture projetée à la
naissance
afin d'éviter toute confusion il ne
s'agit pas de 123 ruptures mais de 123
cas dans les cas une rupture était
envisageable et pour lesquels nous avons
prévenu la NSM afin de gérer au mieux la
situation
alors un tiers de ces notifications
était la conséquence d'une cause externe
c'est-à-dire une augmentation brutale de
la demande ou une tension rupture
affectant incompétiteur et les deux
tiers avaient pour cause un facteur
interne dans 10% du total il s'agissait
d'investigation complémentaire en
matière de qualité
sur l'ensemble des C 123 situations
seules 41 on conduit à une rupture
effective d'approvisionnement ce qui
correspond à environ un tiers des cas la
durée moyenne de ces épisodes de rupture
était de 45 jours en 2022
dans les 82 autres cas c'est-à-dire dans
les deux tiers des cas des solutions ont
été trouvées pour éviter des ruptures et
préserver l'approvisionnement du marché
la réponse à ces situations a été
possible grâce à la détection précoce
détention d'approvisionnement à la mise
en place de mesures de mitigation ou un
identification d'alternative
thérapeutique en interne comme par
exemple une autre présentation pouvant
couvrir le besoin médical concerné
alors je voudrais terminer mon propos en
vous soumettant quelques pistes de
réflexion visant à améliorer la façon
dont nous prévenons et dans nos faisant
face aux situations de tension et de
rupture
il y a eu des débats de plus en plus
nombreux depuis le début de la crise du
covid-19 au sujet de la relocalisation
de la production de médicaments
alors
là c'est un point très important il
serait d'abord impossible et je souligne
le mot impossible de relativiser
relocaliser l'ensemble de la chaîne de
production du médicament en France comme
d'ailleurs dans tout autre pays la
production des médicaments fait appel à
des nombreuses expertises et à de
nombreux acteurs qui ne trouvent pas
tous qui se trouve pas tous au même
endroit je vous donne un exemple et
c'est l'exemple du vaccin contre la
covid-19
ce vaccin est composé de 280 composants
et 9 étapes industrielles elles sont
toutes nécessaires à la fabrication de
ce vaccin alors il serait illusoire de
chercher à tous les à tous les localisés
en un seul pays mais j'irai même plus
loin ce n'est pas ce ne serait pas
souhaitable
notre conviction est que la meilleure
garantie en terme de sécurisation des
chaînes de production et de faire appel
aux meilleurs spécialistes dans chaque
domaine c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour ce vaccin et ses spécialistes sont
localisés dans de nombreux pays
et grâce à cette logique nous avons
réussi à faire preuve de flexibilité
nous avons pu soutenir
l'approvisionnement des patients
français en cœur et éviter toute rupture
concernant le vaccin contre la covid au
plus fort de la crise sanitaire
alors le plus important c'est
l'expertise selon nous et pas la
localisation
nous pensons donc qui serait intéressant
d'inciter les industriels à garantir la
robustesse et l'agilité de leur chaîne
de production plutôt que la
relocalisation en France de leur
production qui n'apportent pas de
garantie suffisante en termes
d'approvisionnement
une autre
solution consiste à faciliter
l'importation de l'eau destinée à des
marchés étrangers en cas de tension où
on avançant sur la mise en place de
notice des matérialisé les fameux qrt ce
qui permettrait de limiter
l'immobilisation de l'eau en cas de
modification à la marche de la notice
nous avons été confrontés à cette
situation en avril 2020 concernant l'un
de nos médicaments de la famille des
corticoïdes
suite à une demande de la part des
autorités de retraites du lactose de
notre produit nous avons été confrontés
à une situation difficile la NSM nous a
accompagné et autorisé à importer des
lots Pfizer destinés au marché belge ce
qui est parmi la prise en charge des
patients français
deux hommes deux autres mesures mesurent
nous paraissent également
intéressantes premièrement il
conviendrait de réfléchir aux conditions
de prix de certains médicaments matures
dont les coûts de production excèdent
parfois le tarif de remboursement
notre expérience de terrain nous montre
également qui conviendrait d’éviter au
maximum tout exigence réglementaire
propre au marché français c'est
particularités peuvent par exemple
concerner le conditionnement primaire de
certains médicaments un alignement
européen serait intéressant afin
d'assurer que certains lots n'est pas à
être produit uniquement pour le marché
français
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je vous
remercie une nouvelle fois pour votre
invitation à m'exprimer devant vous dans
le cadre de votre commission d'enquête
nous nous tenons à votre disposition
pour répondre à l'ensemble de vos
questions merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
laisse immédiatement la parole madame
Laurence Cohen la rapporteur de notre
commission d'enquête pour une première
salle de question
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
tout d'abord permettez-moi de vous
féliciter pour effectivement le vaccin
Pfizer contre la covid parce que ça a
permis de sauver
et bien de nombreuses personnes
par rapport à cette pandémie donc je
voulais quand même
en début de cette commission d'enquête
vous en remercier en mon nom mais je
pense au nom de l'ensemble de la de la
de la commission
il faut de temps en temps aussi pointer
les choses qui vont bien et qui font que
on a on a un système qui qui peut
effectivement résister malgré les
intempéries je dirais à des facteurs
comme les pandémies
Pfizer a annoncé l'année dernière à
l'occasion du sommet annuel chose France
investir 520 millions d'euros en France
pour renforcer ses capacités de
production stimuler aussi la recherche
et l'innovation c'est d'ailleurs ce que
vous avez souligné dans votre dans votre
propos est-ce que vous êtes en mesure
d'estimer ce que représente le marché
français dans le chiffre d'affaires
mondial de Pfizer
dans son excédent brut d'exploitation
mondiale ça c'est ma première question
plusieurs spécialités Pfizer ont
récemment connu des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en France là encore
vous l'avez souligné ces multi
factoriels etc mais c'est le cas par
exemple de la vaincristine qui est un
médicament qui est injectable
commercialisé par Pfizer donc est
utilisé notamment dans le cadre de
chimiothérapie est-ce que vous pouvez
dire devant la commission d'enquête les
causes vraiment de ces tensions même si
elles sont multiples et finalement
comment sur ce médicament précisément
vous avez réussi à sécuriser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement vous l'avez dit
d'une manière on va dire un peu globale
avec les grands principes mais peut-être
par rapport à un exemple concret on se
rend davantage compte et mieux compte de
la façon dont les choses peuvent
s'enchaîner
ensuite il y a une autre une autre
question donc vous avez été je vous ai
remercié en début en mon nom mais au nom
de la commission ça a été fait aussi au
niveau de l'Europe et au niveau mondial
mais concernant
votre entreprise et là était critiquée
notamment par les députés européens de
la commission covid pour son manque de
transparence sur les conditions
tarifaires des contrats qui ont été
conclus notamment pour la livraison des
vaccins c'est très important pour nous
au niveau de la commission d'enquête
parce que on l'a vu dans toutes les
auditions que nous avons pu avoir il y a
un déficit de transparence sur les prix
d'une manière générale et donc là
concernant les vaccins on a entendu
beaucoup beaucoup de choses donc je
voudrais savoir pourquoi dans cet ordre
d'idée pourquoi les contrats qui ont été
signés avec Pfizer entre la Commission
européenne n'ont pas gérant du public
notamment celui de 1,8 milliards de
doses à 19,50 € pour 35 milliards
d'euros pourquoi
Pfizer ne donne pas donc ces éléments
qui concernent les prix les les
responsabilités et les conditions de
livraison parce que je pense et c'est
pas que Pfizer ça s'étend à l'ensemble
des entreprises pharmaceutiques mais ça
aiderait aussi à une meilleure confiance
des des populations d'une manière d'une
manière générale parce qu'il y a des
doutes du coup qui qui sont
qui sont forts dans la population
vous avez également vous avez décidé de
multiplier par 4 le prix du vaccin je
suis toujours dans les dans les
tarifications anticovid aux États-Unis
soit 120 euros contre 30 euros
ultérieurement chercher ok beaucoup de
monde au moment où on a entendu
effectivement ces informations d'autant
que ce qui a circulé au niveau de la
presse c'était que le coût de production
du vaccin anti covid était estimé
beaucoup plus bas donc même on a parlé
de d'appel de Zorro alors effectivement
ça paraissait complètement fou entre
deux euros et 130 dollars ça fait une
majoration de 10000% selon l'Oxfam donc
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dire de ces de
ces écarts de données et puis
effectivement à ce moment-là on voit que
le prix du médicament devient un
obstacle à l'accès aux soins d'un
certain nombre de population
j'aimerais aussi avoir j'ai plus que
deux questions mais j'aimerais aussi
avoir votre appréciation parce que
effectivement vous avez
il y a eu le 26 août 2022
le laboratoire américain moderna qui a
donc lancé une une bataille judiciaire
contre vous en vous accusant d'avoir un
frein des brevets sur les technologies
essentielles à son vaccin ARN messager
contre la covid-19 donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus puisque
d'après moderna ce serait deux de ces
brevets qui auraient été en frein donc
c'est aussi important parce que quand on
quand on quand je dis ça c'est pas c'est
pas dans une histoire de montée de labo
les uns contre les autres mais à partir
du moment où il y a ces données là ça
peut être un frein pour effectivement la
possibilité de l'accès aux soins et ça
peut créer effectivement des tensions au
niveau des des médicaments
la commission d'enquête puisque j'ai lu
que des chercheurs américains de santé
publique ou d'économie de la santé ont
étudié le prix de 58 médicaments
anticancéreux entre 1995 et 2013 et
selon cette étude les médicaments les
plus restreints les plus récents pardon
n'ont pas augmenté la durée de survie
par rapport aux médicaments les plus
anciens par contre le prix des
médicaments à fortement augmenté
concernant ces produits donc voilà voilà
mes questions dans un premier temps
elles sont multiples mais effectivement
vous êtes face à une commission
d'enquête je vous remercie par avance
pour vos réponses et je me réjouis que à
la tête de Pfizer il y a des pharmaciens
monsieur le Président je vous laisse
répondre
dans l'ordre
alors quand vous vous me demandez par
rapport à la part de la France la part
de la France en général du marché
pharmaceutique mondial en général c'est
pas seulement en fait ils ont en général
c'est un 4% 4% du 4 %
ça c'est
en général ça peut bien sûr pour des
sociétés qui sont basées en France des
sociétés françaises ça sera plus etc
mais quand on prend la moyenne
d'industrie
ces 4% maintenant le marché français je
vous donne aussi une autre information
c'est que c'est le cinquième marché
mondial c'est un marché important et
c'est le cinquième marché mondial
alors si on les prend dans l'ordre
numéro 1 c'est des États-Unis numéro 2
c'est la Chine numéro 3 c'est le Japon
numéro 4 c'est l'Allemagne au 5 c'est la
France
deuxième question
deuxième question rupture par rapport à
la vigne Christine un produit très
important car c'est une chimiothérapie
utilisée dans un certain nombre de
protocoles contre des tumeurs ça peut
être soit hémontologique soit des
tumeurs solides afin d'avoir plus de
je dirais de détails je passe la parole
à Franck
oui alors dans le cas de la voix
Christine donc il y a en France deux
principaux acteurs
du fournissent un Christine dont Pfizer
et donc ce qui s'est passé là c'était
donc ça rentre dans les ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les causes externes à
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
une des entreprises qui étaient en
difficulté pour s'approvisionner de
mémoire la cause était
alors donc le principal actif est un
alcaloïde qui est extrait de plantes
donc il n'y a pas que des principes
actifs qui sont de synthèse il peut y
avoir aussi des origines animales et
donc il y a des aléas qui peuvent
arriver comme des aléas climatiques et
c'est ce qui s'est passé les récoltes
ont été mauvaises et donc il y avait des
difficultés à
trouver le principe actif
on a d'autres principes actifs sur
d'autres produits qui peuvent être
d'origine animale qui peuvent être aussi
sujets à des aléas comme des épidémies
[Musique]
par exemple ou ce genre de situation
donc face à cette situation donc Pfizer
lui était pas en situation de difficulté
mais ce qui était très important c'est
justement cette coopération c'est-à-dire
contre l'entreprise on peut pas se
parler mais on peut parler à nos
autorités donc il y a eu tout de suite
une organisation à travers des autorités
donc la NSM pour envisager des solutions
et donc l'entreprise reser mobilisée
pour venir en renfort nous avons cherché
des solutions de notre côté puisque les
stocks que nous avions
n'auraient pas suffi à couvrir tous les
besoins donc nous avons pu trouver trois
lots qui étaient déjà fabriqués
disponibles et qui était initialement
destinés au marché espagnol et donc la
NSA nous a accompagnés pour
évaluer ces produits nous donner une
autorisation de pouvoir les importer et
donc on a eu de ce fait une quantité
additionnelle
aux quantité qui était initialement
prévue
donc c'est vraiment pour moi la
coopération de tous les acteurs qui
alors l'anticipation dans la détection
qui est vraiment clé parce que plus on a
de temps plus on va trouver de solutions
comme vous la direz d'Inde les causes de
rupture on n'a pas trouvé une cause
principale on aurait réglé le problème
il y a vraiment une multitude de causes
il faut être très agile il faut détecter
très tôt et très agile pour pouvoir
trouver les solutions qui vont
fonctionner pour cette cause dans un
contexte très spécifique
et donc dans tous les cas la coopération
l'anticipation et la coopération avec
les autorités
qui nous accompagnent vraiment et que je
remercie beaucoup et très très
importante et c'est ce qui a permis de
traverser ici une situation qui n'était
pas du tout évidente quand on a analysé
des données
alors la troisième question c'était sur
les conditions tarifaires etc le
contrat européen alors
écoutez les les le contrat le contrat du
vaccin contre la covid est un contrat
qui sont cédé contrats qui sont discutés
au niveau de notre mise en mer
directement avec la Commission
européenne au niveau de l'Europe
cette partie relève vraiment du secret
des affaires
mis en place c'est à dire c'est ça fait
vraiment partie des secrets des affaires
alors au niveau de la France et c'est ce
que nous contrôlons ici c'est au niveau
de la France nous avons travaillé mais
dans la mer avec la terre force depuis
le début et nous en sommes toujours en
discussion et notamment par rapport au
livraison
et ça c'est la responsabilité ma
responsabilité et la responsabilité de
pfizer france
par rapport
au prix du vaccin alors le prix du
vaccin
je ne peux pas me prononcer au niveau
des États-Unis je m'occupe pas ce par
contre
par rapport à la France vous savez en
France le marché est régulé
il y a des règles
et même la l'évolution du marché
lui-même le marché pharmaceutique et
quand vous regardez par exemple
l'évolution et là je réponds à deux
questions en même temps regardez
l'évolution du marché pharmaceutique
français depuis 2009 à 2019 et ça ça
répond à votre question par rapport à
toute l'innovation il est stable et ça
c'est malgré c'est à dire que
l'enveloppe est la même malgré
l'introduction d'un certain nombre
d'innovations
vous prenez par exemple il y a des
innovations en thérapie génique
d'innovation quand même en oncologie qui
ont apporté beaucoup de bénéfices
cliniques aux patients
elles ont été introduites et mises en
disposition à disposition des patients
ça c'est une chose et ça c'est malgré le
fait que
la population française entre temps a
augmenté il y a
je dirais beaucoup la population
vieillit alors elle consomme plus de
médicaments et quand vous regardez tout
cela vous vous voyez un marché qui quand
même une enveloppe par rapport à nos
voisins européens qui est stable elle
est stable elle n'a pas changé de 2009 à
2019 alors ça c'est un point
très important
quand vous le savez en France il y a des
règles très claires quand je vous parle
des règles c'est-à-dire que on passe par
la chasse comité de transparence il y a
la SMS la SMR et puis vas-y sur la SMR
que ça soit une semaine 1 2 3 ou 4 ou 5
c'est là où à ce moment-là basé sur cela
et les discussions avec le CVS et c'est
comme ça que le prix est fixé ça suit
des règles
un mot très important encore une fois je
reviens aux innovations par rapport aux
innovations en France j'ai une
opportunité de travailler dans beaucoup
de pays j'ai travaillé en Italie j'ai
travaillé en Angleterre je suis même
passé par les États-Unis et je peux vous
dire qu'en France le marché est très
régulier pour tout ce qui est innovation
vous avez tout d'abord en général pour
le marché pharmaceutique non seulement
l'innovation vous avez les bases de prix
qui sont assez importantes chaque année
vous avez aussi
la clause de sauvegarde qui impacte
toute l'industrie vous avez aussi les
remises les accords
avec le CPAS il y a un impact sur la
remise alors tout cela quelque part
régule le marché et j'aimerais souligner
le fait que ça régule le marché beaucoup
plus que nos voisins européens
et puis il y a bien sûr les les taxes
sectoriels en France vous avez des taxes
qui sont entre 24 et 40% en Espagne ça
va de 14 à 21 % et les autres pays on
est autour du 5 % de 5%
par rapport
au brevet alors le brevet
alors par rapport au brevet moderna
moderna c'est une
question qui relève de notre maison mère
la procédure est en cours je ne suis pas
habilité à la commenter
je peux vous parler beaucoup des
innovations si nous avons le temps mais
comme je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions
si vous voulez je peux continuer sur les
innovations
pardon juste quelques mots quelques mots
sur les innovations parce que on est on
est toujours coincé entre va coincé
c'est une façon de dire mais je veux
dire que il faut réussir à sortir de ce
problème qui nous est souvent renvoyé
enfin en tout cas depuis que nous avons
débuté les auditions entre d'un côté les
produits matures qui seraient trop bas
et de l'autre côté les produits
innovants qui sont vraiment très très
hauts donc arrivé à trouver un équilibre
si je puis dire qui permettent à chaque
patient de recevoir le traitement dont
il a besoin et sans sans jouer sur un
espèce de chantage sur
l'un des produits ou l'autre et ce que
je voulais dire dans ma question c'était
que qui dit on a vu que le service rendu
parfois j'étais bien parfois sur par
certains produits dit innovants n'est
pas meilleur que le produit rendu par
certaines molécules matures et donc
voilà comment est-ce qu'on arrive à je
sais pas si c'est régulé ou en tout cas
faire en sorte que il n'y ait pas
cette abandon des molécules matures pour
courir vers des innovations qui ne sont
pas toujours au rendez-vous du service
qu'on attend c'est ça ma question plus
précise
écoutez tout tout médicament qui est mis
à disposition des patients c'est à dire
que c'est des médicaments qui apportent
un bénéfice clinique ça c'est sans doute
c'est une décision qui est prise
d'ailleurs par les autorités compétentes
le M1 l'enregistrement et puis la SM et
puis ça passe par la chaise et le CFS
pour tout ce qui est créatrice au prix
maintenant la décision la décision et la
décision du professionnel de santé de
prescrire un produit ou l'autre
il y a je répète il y a beaucoup
d'innovations
quand vous avez des outils cliniques
vous avez des outils cliniques qui sont
comparables des phases froides et des
phases froid comparables vont comparez
une innovation un nouveau médicament par
rapport à ce qui est actuellement
la référence la référence qui est
utilisée la référence clinique et c'est
basé sur ses résultats que les produits
numéro 1 sont enregistrés au niveau
européen et puis sont évalués au niveau
de la chasse et la communauté de
transparence et puis au niveau du prix
après c'est ça dépend du SMS et c'est
basé sur la SMR que le CFS
bien sûr en négociant avec nous décide
sur le prix
c'est un système très régulier par
rapport à d'autres pays à nos voisins
merci beaucoup je vais passer aux
questions de notre collègues Pascal
Grigny et ensuite Jean-Pierre mockin
merci
[Musique]
moi j'ai une question sur les maladies
rares voilà parce que c'est un vrai
sujet tout à l'heure on a entendu une
association est-ce que vous travaillez
sur ces sujets là on sait bien que ça
concerne très peu de personnes à
rentabilité forcément pas là mais est-ce
que vous avez des programmes pour
répondre à plusieurs maladies rares ou
pas du tout voilà ma deuxième question
ça concerne les stocks
parce qu'il y a des obligations de stock
est-ce que d'abord est-ce que vous
suivez c'est ces stocks est-ce que parce
que on nous dit que certains
laboratoires ne feraient pas les stocks
de demander qu'est-ce que ça représente
comme coût pour vous comment vous les
gérez parce qu'on sait bien que il y a
des dates des délais donc si aujourd'hui
c'est de moi si demain on vous dit
quatre mois est-ce que ça c'est quelque
chose de possible justement par rapport
à ces assez dates et on a reçu aussi
justement les laboratoires et où ils
nous disait je crois que c'était aux
États-Unis ou quand il y avait justement
une pénurie qu'ils avaient la
possibilité d'avoir un site dans lequel
en fait il était très rapidement
possible de faire une nouvelle
production en cas de demande
exceptionnelle est-ce que vous aussi
vous avez ce
genre de possibilités sur sur vos lignes
de production
donc on va passer aux questions on va
prendre les questions de Jean-Pierre
Moga également et puis Annick jacquemais
qui s'est rajouté merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président d'abord
je voudrais moi aussi salut
ce que vous avez fait avec votre
entreprise pendant le
la crise et le problème du covid et
c'est rubans quelque chose à saluer vous
allez dire à part que j'ai mal compris
qu'il était impossible de relocaliser et
certainement vos raisons
alors relocaliser moi je vois
relocaliser je sais pas comment on voit
mes collègues mais peut-être pas
relocaliser tout en France mais au moins
en Europe parce qu'il y a quand même et
on l'a vu aussi il y avait le covid avec
la guerre à l'Ukraine qui avait quand
même des questions de souveraineté
d'indépendance et
quand on fabrique des éléments un peu
partout dans le monde et qu'on les
regroupe après pour faire le produit
final que ce soit des médicaments
d'ailleurs ou autre chose mais si au
niveau international il y a une crise
comme on connaît actuellement avec les
problèmes qu'on a avec la Russie avait
l'Ukraine etc est-ce que les il y a pas
des enjeux et des problèmes quand même
qu'ils font que vous pourriez à un
moment donné être à la situation de ne
plus pouvoir produire parce que une
partie de votre activité
se trouverait dans des endroits où vous
ne pouvez plus utiliser vos vos
usines etc donc je m'interroger par
rapport à ça moi il me semble que au
niveau peut-être pas entièrement au
niveau français mais au niveau européen
l'Europe offre quand même une stabilité
un certain nombre de garanties
d'indépendance et devrait pouvoir
permettre parce que je me trompe
de pouvoir relocaliser sur l'ensemble
après je vous ai entendu aussi parler
des problèmes d'alignement européenne
par rapport aux spécifications je pense
de fabrication de présentation etc et
effectivement mais ma question là aussi
est-ce que vous travaillez avec la
Commission européenne pour voir si on
peut pas arriver à une idée aligner dans
ce domaine-là comme dans notre Domaine
pour faciliter les choses pour les
entreprises dans votre domaine ou dans
d'autres je vous remercie
excusez-moi on va vous faire toutes les
questions d'un coup et puis
vous notez
dame merci pour Monsieur pour votre
exposé bien sûr je joins mes
remerciements à ceux de mes collègues
pour les vaccins moi j'ai une petite
question un peu plus technique à vous
poser et est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer pourquoi en médecine humaine
on ne déconditionne pas les médicaments
comme on le fait en médecine vétérinaire
ou très souvent médecine vétérinaire on
a des boîtes de 500 ou 1000 comprimés
d'antibiotiques en détail en fonction du
traitement antibiotique ou autre
anti-inflammatoire enfin toutes sortes
de médicaments qu'on détaille en
fonction de la pathologie de la du poids
de l'animal de la durée de traitement
etc et je suis toujours surprise que ça
ne se fasse pas en médecine humaine
alors est-ce qu'il y a des raisons
particulières est-ce que c'est un
problème administratif juridique ou
voilà pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a une
telle différence entre les deux façons
je sais bien que d'un côté des animaux
et de l'autre côté des humains mais
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez me donner
une explication d'autant que Pfizer nous
fournissez un certain nombre de
médicaments et on a l'habitude et vous
savez bien agir dans ce sens-là merci
donc Pascal venir repose une toute
petite question je suis désolé
c'est moi
j'ai bien compris le marché stable on va
dire contraint aussi en France à
l'intérieur de ça vous avez des
consommations qui qui peuvent augmenter
vous avez parlé de la population qui qui
a augmenté aussi une population
vieillissante des médicaments innovants
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'à l'intérieur
de ça finalement vous abandonnez
certains médicaments pour pouvoir
justement répondre aux demandes des
médicaments innovants et du coup ça
génère bien sûr des pénuries parce que
il y a des anciens médicaments qui qui
sont toujours quand même en attente de
passion
et donc moi parce que moi aussi j'ai des
questions
je vous en prie je vous en prie
vous avez vous avez évoqué des pénuries
le seul 41 sur le sur le stock de départ
à risque de de rupture
en 2022 et sont donc des médicaments qui
ont été soumis à contingentement je
suppose c'est à dire que ils ont été
distribués mais à doses filées voilà et
comment vous gérez cette question du
contingentement dans la mesure où ça
provoque quand même des des situations
extrêmement difficiles du point de vue
du prescripteur et du patient bien
évidemment est-ce que vous êtes proactif
dans la distribution et comment comment
vous gérez cette question la
distribution des doses
sur la question des contrats avec
l'Europe pour le vaccin en fait ce qui a
été reproché c'est que c'était les
pouvoirs publics qui prenaient le risque
c'est-à-dire que dans le contrat en fait
peu de risques étaient assumé par par le
laboratoire
il y avait de telles contraintes on se
rappelle de logistique de température
etc etc qu'il y avait peu de chances que
de toute façon le risque soit attribué
au laboratoire on aurait forcément
trouvé une faille dans la distribution
derrière ça c'est beaucoup passionné
depuis mais c'est vrai que au départ
c'était extrêmement rigide donc c'était
un peu ça qui a fait que la question de
la transparence c'est vraiment a été
évoqué sur sur cette question des
contrats et même s'il y a le secret des
affaires vous savez bien qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'outils qui pour
l'instant n'ont pas été utilisés mais en
quelque sorte l'Europe a pris goût à la
santé surtout en situation d'urgence et
que ça pourrait bien que ces outils
soient un jour mobilisés donc comment
vous vous préparez à cette situation
potentielle parce qu'on sent que le vent
tourne un peu quand même aussi
possiblement dans ce sens là
sur la relocalisation
quelle est la faille en fait sur toute
la chaîne du médicament est-ce que ça
dépend médicaments ou est-ce que
vraiment la faille c'est plutôt la
partie chimie parce qu'on a le sentiment
que c'est un peu ça ce sont les
principales actifs et les excipients
mais est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a un
potentiel pour que les savoir-faire les
compétences se redéveloppent à nouveau
en France et si ce n'est en France au
moins en Europe et que on puisse
progressivement revenir à un niveau
d'autonomie et de compétences qui nous
permettrait nous aussi de produire un
certain nombre de principes actifs qui
sont pour certains
gérés par des des monopoles et quand et
qui dit monopole dit grand risque est
grand danger pour la santé et pas que en
France la santé mondiale et on voit bien
que ça c'est un des gros éléments de
fragilité de l'Organisation Mondiale du
médicament ces dernières années voilà
j'ai fini pour mes questions je vous
remercie
on vous répondant peut-être que comme il
y a des questions qui sont quelque part
connectées on donne une réponse très
bien alors je commence avec les maladies
rares écoutez par rapport aux maladies
rares je vous rejoins à 100%
alors tout d'abord Pfizer ça fait partie
des
6 Hertz hermétiques dans lesquelles nous
faisons beaucoup de recherches et
d'ailleurs il existe un portefeuille
aujourd'hui qui est mis à disposition
des patients en France et mondialement
un point important sur les maladies
rares
seulement pour vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
il existe 7000 maladies rares des 7000
maladies rares on a uniquement autour de
maladies qui sont prises en recherche ce
qui veut dire qu'il reste des milliers
de maladies rares alors qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait nous avons créé au niveau de
faizer ça c'était en la lancé c'était en
février 2022
une
un consortium au niveau européen c'est à
dire nous avons nous sommes au niveau de
l'association de l'industrie
pharmaceutique au niveau européen le FPA
ils ont lancé un programme dans Pfizer a
pris le je vais dire le leadership là
dessus et ce programme là
c'est un certain nombre d'industries de
des entreprises de médicaments qui ont
un intérêt dans les maladies rares qui
le lance qui finance
et qui ont pris comme je vais dire
comme partenaire
des centres de recherche publique et le
centre qui a pris le leadership dans
tout ce modèle européen ça a été une
serviable on a insisté en France que ça
soit les cernes qui soient
qui prennent le leadership là le fer de
lance de tout cela alors ce programme là
aujourd'hui a été présenté à la
Commission européenne et puis c'est à la
Commission européenne
il devrait coûter quelque part autour de
48 millions de d'euros la moitié c'est
l'industrie pharmaceutique et puis à la
Commission européenne ils sont en train
de l'analyser pour voir s'ils peuvent
compléter la deuxième moitié et on est
très fier car c'est la France quelque
part qui guide ce programme qui
s'appelle
ERD au carré c'est
européen
alors ça c'est par rapport à et
d'ailleurs je voulais aussi dire autre
chose importante c'est que vous savez
dans les maladies rares vous avez des
maladies rares mais des maladies ultra
rares qu'est-ce que ça veut dire vous
avez des maladies ou en France on a un
apparent comment peut-on développer un
produit pour un cas et c'est ces
maladies là sur lesquelles
on collabore avec les centres de
recherche pour trouver des solutions
même d'enregistrement plus tard alors
nous allons aussi travailler avec le M1
pour voir comment est-ce qu'on garde par
exemple un
protocole à vie ou les patients peuvent
rentrer à vie et puis quand on arrive
peut-être à une centaine de patients ça
ça sera dans 20 ans on pourra
enregistrer c'est très complexe et sur
lequel c'est le dossier sur lequel on
travaille et je répète parce qu'on est
très fier on a beaucoup ouvré là dessus
c'est que la France a pris le leadership
avec l'Islam alors ça c'est la question
la première question
alors deuxième question c'était les
stocks
c'est bon vous m'attendez alors oui vous
nous avez posé la question comment
finalement on gérait on gérait les
stocks donc c'est peut-être en deux
phases moi je vous explique la première
c'est toute la relation et le travail
qui est fait par notre supply chaînes et
après il y a tout le travail qui est
fait par l'équipe de France et notamment
toutes les relations avec la NSM donc
déjà pour pour gérer ses stocks il faut
savoir même en France on a un outil on
dispose d'un outil SAP où on a
l'intégralité des stocks avec un
paramétrage qui est de minimum 60 jours
et qui va jusqu'à 75 jours
donc cet outil SAP et nous disposons
aussi d'un outil d'intelligence
artificielle qui calcule en temps réel
finalement via un algorithme
l'alignement entre les stocks que l'on a
les prévisions de vente et les ventes
donc il y a une adaptation qui peut qui
se qui se fait il faut savoir que tous
les jours tous les jours l'équipe en
charge de ces stocks surveillent
justement vente révision et si jamais
ils voient que on n'a pas un alignement
ils vont se poser la question de
pourquoi et voir quel est ce qu'il y a
un problème éventuel parce que il y a
une rupture ailleurs en tout cas essayez
essayez de comprendre ce qui se passe et
voir comment on peut réajuster ensuite
avec les équipes de de la qualité il y a
également toutes les semaines une
cellule qui réfléchit qui voit quelles
sont les produits critiques et là tout
de suite les décisions sont prises et la
NSM et
informée après
on pourrait revenir réagir à une à une à
une rupture par rapport à notre supply
ça peut prendre du temps comme on l'a
dit c'est soit une importation de l'eau
et dans ce cas là ça veut dire des
nouvelles variations par des nouvelles
normes ou relancer une chaîne de
production ce qui demande pour dédier à
la France qui demande du temps et
peut-être le deuxième temps est
important c'est aussi la qualité
je vais essayer il y a trois questions
sur la production monsieur sénateur la
présidente
ce que je peux partager avec vous c'est
notre stratégie de production
c'est la philosophie mais c'est propre à
ses propres alors la façon dont on a
construit notre réseau et je parle
surtout de réseau mondialement on a créé
des réseaux et c'est basé sur le
savoir-faire
ça dépend des produits vous avez des
produits de ce qu'on appelle chimique
qui passe par trois étapes trois étapes
et ce qu'on fait par rapport à ces
produits les produits chimiques trois
étapes c'est qu'on essaye de les
de créer un réseau où il y a du
savoir-faire pour chaque étape
pour chaque étape pourquoi parce qu'on
sait en répétant et répétant on crée un
centre d'excellence
ok on termine de qualité ce qui est très
important maintenant
ça c'est pour des produits par exemple
chimiques
le deuxième point c'est que si vous
allez à l'extrême vous prenez les
vaccins ou vous prenez la thérapie
génique je veux vous donner l'exemple
des vaccins nous avons un vaccin qui
s'appelle le CIC un vaccin contre les
suprêmes narthèses contre les pneumonies
chaque dose de ce vaccin mobilise plus
de 1700 personnes sur la ligne de
production tout au long de la chaîne de
production il a 400 composantes 400
composantes
591 étapes
et 678 test en matière de qualité
678 pour
produire un flacon c'est 24 mois en mai
24 mois et ça vous démontre quelque part
la difficulté quand on fait les
prévisions il faut les faire très en
amont alors ça c'est le deuxième point
alors je vous ai donné les deux extrêmes
je vous ai donné les deux extrêmes
maintenant notre philosophie a été
d'assurer que l'Europe
que la plupart de ces jeux de la
production de nos médicaments et de nos
vaccins
soit situé en Europe et aujourd'hui sur
le marché français
98% des médicaments qui sont et des
vaccins surtout qui sont
distribués en France émanent de l'Europe
alors ça c'est notre quelque part notre
sécurité maintenant il y a un autre
point important c'est que pour chacun de
ces
on parle de réseau
de production pour chacune de ces usines
il y a ce qu'on appelle le backup c'est
à dire au cas où par exemple il y a un
problème comment réaloue la production à
une autre soit dans l'usine à un autre
ligne rapidement soit à une autre usine
et
je peux vous dire que nous l'avons
utilisé à maintes reprises dans le passé
un point aussi alors comme vous voyez
tout cela quand je peux regarder d'un
produit qui a 400 composants 581 états
industrielle ça passe par quand même un
certain nombre de pays c'est très
difficile de mettre tout dans un pays et
aussi en termes de sécurité vous voulez
pas tout mettre dans un seul pays
alors je crois que j'ai répondu à tout
ce qui est
ce que j'ai répondu à votre question
qu'on vous avait parlé comment peut-on
assurer que l'Europe
sécurise la production c'est ce qui est
une faille est-ce qu'il y a un déficit
de compétence qui a été identifié sur la
chaîne du médicament c'était un peu ça
le sujet par exemple pour le vaccin vous
avez eu besoin que le flaconnage soit
pris en charge par une autre entreprise
alors il y a eu évidemment il a fallu
sortir vite beaucoup de loups beaucoup
de stocks mais est-ce que
alors du point de vue de Pfizer
évidemment de voilà mais d'une manière
générale est-ce qu'il y a il y a des
failles qui ont été identifiées
c'est-à-dire si on veut vraiment passer
un gap important en matière de
souveraineté médicamenteuse quels sont
les domaines de compétences dans
lesquels on a besoin de réindustrialiser
est-ce que c'est plutôt la chimie est-ce
que voilà c'est un peu ces sujets là
c'était ça je passe la parole à
Catherine oui peut-être sur l'exemple du
du vaccin donc on a on a quand même une
nouvelle technologie avec la ARN
messager
donc c'est vrai que
la décision de fazer la stratégie de
Pfizer a été d'utiliser les usines que
nous avions déjà et notamment pur c'est
d'investir massivement à purs ou l'usine
avait déjà
les compétences et le niveau le niveau
de qualité c'est ce qui a permis aussi
que ça a beaucoup plus vite
c'est vrai que par rapport à la RN
messager si on regarde les compétences
sur cette
molécule n'existe pas vraiment en France
ça c'est une problématique la stratégie
de Pfizer en termes de de
d'industrialisation c'est ou de
travailler avec nos sites qui sont très
performants et on n'a pas de rupture
ou de
travailler avec des partenaires mais des
partenaires avec qui on a une exigence
de qualité et qui ont les bonnes
compétences après il nous arrive aussi
de travailler et de faire ce qu'on
appelle du transfert de technologie donc
d'investir dans ces centres mais voilà
c'est un coût Dubout c'est un coup
supplémentaire et pour et pour les
vaccins
il fallait quand même aller aller très
très vite et avec avec un niveau de
sûreté qui est et on n'a jamais eu de
rupture par contre si on regarde toute
la chaîne
un certain nombre on l'a dit il y a 280
composants on avait notamment neuf
façonniers en France alors des
façonniers qui peuvent produire le
bouchon le flacon enfin des filtres ça
venait absolument de partout et le
flaconnage oui il y a Bayonne tech a
fait un partenaire un partenariat avec
Delpharm
et ça
aussi quand vous m'avez parlé c'est la
chimie c'est qu'elle alors il y a d'une
part le savoir-faire des nouvelles
technologies par exemple la thérapie
génique il faudrait la développer en
Europe aujourd'hui vous la trouvez en
Suisse uniquement ça c'est quelque chose
sur lequel il faut travailler la
deuxième c'est la production des
matières premières pour tous les
produits d'origine chimique
donc quelques cas ça serait très
compliqué de les relocaliser en Europe
tout ce qui est matière première du fait
des normes environnementales en vigueur
vous connaissez le reach le fameux riche
alors ça c'est aussi un point un autre
point important par rapport à quelques
molécules
il y a des exceptions dans riches donc
on peut aussi en décider au fur et à
mesure et l'urgence ou la nécessité
sanitaire peut faire peu porter ses
exceptions mais
[Musique]
ça faut le regarder de près cette
question là d'accord mais c'est un sujet
à soulever effectivement
et puis par rapport à la réflexion
européenne même française
madame la rapporteur vous m'avez vous
avez évoqué l'investissement en France
ça a été avec
un sous-traitant un façonnier
novase qui se trouve au
périnées-atlantiques et c'est là où nous
avons fait un investissement afin qu'il
puisse produire
le principe actif d'une molécule très
stratégique c'est le paxo vide le
pacsoïs c'est l'antiviral
l'antiviral contre le vaccin et
l'exportation du principe actif sera
faite de la France pour l'international
en dehors bien sûr de l'Amérique du Nord
alors ça c'est un autre exemple
on travaille énormément afin d'attirer
de la production en France et notamment
avec des sous-traitants
ce qui est important quand même
c'est
je répète ce que j'avais dit au début
c'est à dire il faut vraiment
diversifier
les sites de production et avoir de la
flexibilité sur la chaîne de production
et puis il y avait l'autre le
déconditionnement des médicaments
oui alors déjà en France en général les
conditionnements sont adaptées à l'usage
de l'indication le plus souvent
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont le nombre
d'unités qui est attendu par rapport à
l'indication et le traitement ensuite il
y a beaucoup d'efforts qui sont faits
alors il y a la stérilisation avec les
numéros uniques pour éviter les
contrefaçons il y a des dispositifs d'un
vieux labilité sur les boîtes donc en
fait tout ça vise à protéger aussi les
patients et donc effectivement c'est un
conçu pour des conditionner en état
actuel et puis il y a la question aussi
des notices donc on revient aussi sur
les réflexions de d'information pour les
patients qui pourraient aussi
aujourd'hui être
utilisé les moyens du digital pour être
plus rapidement je dirais adapté aux
circonstances et ont besoin mais de fait
aujourd'hui les boîtes elles sont plutôt
sceller et avec un numéro d'identifiant
chacune plutôt dans l'esprit de
d'éviter enfin de le risque de d'être
exposé à des contrefaçons
ouais mais sur les enfin nous en
médecine vétérinaire les lots et les
dates de péremption sont marqués sur les
plaquettes et on a des pochettes et des
notices pour chaque plaquette donc
ça demande un travail supplémentaire
c'est sur les boîtes arrivent pas toutes
faites mais ouais je comprends pas très
bien enfin sauf si c'est réglementaire
et auquel cas vous avez répondu à ma
question mais quand vous dites c'est une
question de stérilisation
je comprends que les comprimés dans les
dans les mystères soient stériles mais
une fois que la boîte est ouverte la
stérilisation toute façon
ce que je voulais vous expliquer c'est
tout le dispositif réglementaire qui est
un choix de société aussi visait plutôt
à protéger les boîtes c'est les boîtes
tracer les boîtes pour protéger les
patients d'un risque de contrefaçon
plutôt que
prévoir une dispositions pour une
dispensation immunité c'était plutôt les
choix qui me défendent plein industriel
s'adapte
après moi mon point de vue c'est que
dans la mesure où la boîte répond aux
besoins par rapport à une indication ce
choix il est c'est un bon choix
il y avait la question du contingent
penser à comment on risque on vous gérez
l'avant pénurie c'est-à-dire tout ce
moment un peu flou ou on a du stock mais
pas suffisamment et il commence à se
passe dans c'est plutôt avec les
hôpitaux souvent que c'est ces sujets là
se gèrent mais comme comment vous
faussez-vous qu'il fonctionnait en
direct et comment comment vous arbitrer
en fait dans vos stocks c'est quand même
alors c'est là où la connaissance du
produit et donc quelque part aussi dans
l'esprit des plans de gestion de pénurie
on va pour chaque produit et ITM donc on
va identifier le besoin on va avoir une
réflexion également par rapport à nos
parts de marché donc elle serait
l'impact en cas de mouvement de boîte et
par canal de distribution parce que
quelquefois l'impact est différent on
peut avoir quelques fois être tout seul
en ville par exemple parce que et puis à
l'hôpital il y a des alternatives donc
c'est important de savoir que en cas de
tension on va pouvoir fermer un canal
pour privilégier le cas d'un ça fait des
options des options dont on va disposer
on va chercher toutes les options
possibles pour tenir alors une durée
qu'on connaît pas forcément c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir une estimation voilà la
gestion d'une pénurie c'est comme la
gestion des stocks c'est revu en
dynamique en permanence c'est-à-dire que
on revoit les données les nouvelles
données on revoit si la stratégie est
toujours adaptée et surtout cela en
coopération avec la NSM c'est à dire
qu'on va les informer on va leur
proposer des solutions ils vont arbitrer
ces solutions ça fait un deuxième
expertise également et ensuite on va
mettre en oeuvre les solutions et puis
chaque fois qu'on a une nouvelle
information on va revenir vers les
autorités on va revoir nos propositions
on va attendre leur approbation ou leur
avis et on va mettre en oeuvre ces
solutions donc c'est vraiment une
gestion dynamique qui prend beaucoup de
temps à des équipes d'experts qui vont
revoir les données collecter ces données
et revoir les données en permanence
après donc c'est aussi les connaissances
du produit donc on va savoir quel est le
niveau supportable on va dire sans trop
de désagréments on va essayer d'être
assez cela dans la mesure de nos
possibilités et au fur et à mesure du
temps donc si une approbation est
arrivée problème est résolue si on doit
faire face à le délai plus long il va
falloir adapté à chaque fois et on va
toujours penser essayer de privilégier
les besoins les plus urgent
alors après il y a l'équité de
répartition aussi parce que quand il y a
une tension
moi je suis pharmacien aussi je vais
avoir envie de faire du stock même si
j'en ai pas besoin me disant au cas où
donc il faut aussi savoir résister et
c'est là où la coopération tous les
acteurs est importante pensez patient
et pour nous on a toujours eu un point
d'honneur aussi à servir tous les
établissements qui soient client sizer
on va considérer le besoin immédiat j'ai
besoin médical le plus urgent et on fera
le maximum c'est c'est vraiment ce qu'on
est à l'esprit des équipes et puis de la
ligne directrice donc après tout va
dépendre de la situation il n'y a pas
deux rupture qui se ressemblent et même
sur un même produit si vous avez
plusieurs ruptures au cours du temps ça
va pas être forcément la même situation
et la même gestion et au cours du temps
on peut être amené à revoir adapté à
chaque nouvelle information et on le
fait en coopération avec les autorités
en pensant quelle est la meilleure
option pour les patients
pas directement avec les établissements
alors ensuite on communique avec les
établissements on propose aux autorités
on voit si la solution proposée leur
convient ici c'est le cas on la décline
et on la communique
dernière question et après oui parce
qu'en fait on rebondit sur les les
éléments le temps que en fait on vous
pose des questions vous n'aurez vous
nous répondez et puis du coup ça fait
venir d'autres d'autres questionnements
parce que moi j'ai dans les échanges que
nous avons eu donc
vous avez vous avez insisté sur le fait
que vous essayez de consacrer en tout
cas votre vos efforts pour faire en
sorte que il y ait une production qui
soit faite j'allais dire au plus proche
en France en Europe
vous avez insisté sur la question de
sécurisation aussi comme étant une
exigence enfin autant de critères autant
de critères qui pour nous
sont très très importants et moi je
voudrais un peu avoir plus d'éléments
parce que on a vu si on en est
aujourd'hui dans cette situation là
alors je vais puisque vous restez sur la
France assez sur la France en France
c'est pas une politique récente c'est
une politique qui depuis au moins 30 ans
d'avoir délocalisé etc et aujourd'hui ce
sont les conséquences de cette politique
là il y avait une stratégie et il y a un
certain nombre de de vos concurrents qui
étaient basés en France et qui ont
beaucoup
externalisés et qui ont d'ailleurs
brader des sites de production ou fermés
pour ne pas dire brader et du coup
licencier un certain nombre de de
chercheurs d'ailleurs et maintenant on
s'aperçoit que et ben on manque de de
sites et on manque de chercheurs et moi
je voudrais je voudrais vous poser cette
cette question alors on manque de
chercheurs mais aussi on nous a dit je
sais plus à quelle à quelle audition que
c'était pas seulement les chercheurs qui
manquaient c'était y compris des
techniciens qui avaient un savoir-faire
important voilà donc on est quand même
un peu étonné et on se pose des
questions et je vois bien
si on lit tous les articles qui sont
consacrés à l'industrie pharmaceutique
et notamment à Pfizer que vous êtes en
pleine expansion et c'est une bonne
chose c'est pas voilà c'est pas un
élément négatif mais dans cette dans
cette entreprise qui est donc en
croissance vous avez annoncé il y a pas
longtemps il y a quelques jours enfin
annoncé racheté ses gammes qui est le
spécialiste des chimiothérapie pour à
peu près on va dire 45 milliards de
dollars alors bon pourquoi pas si c'est
pour effectivement sécuriser la
chimiothérapie faire en sorte que ça
soit relocalisé etc mais moi ma question
parce que on le constate quand même ce
genre de stratégie est-ce que le fait de
d'acheter comme ça un certain nombre de
d'entreprises pour grossir grossir
grossir est-ce que ça ne porte pas
préjudice à une politique justement qui
devrait se consacrer
développement d'une activité du principe
actif notamment notamment en Europe ou
par l'amélioration de la sécurisation
c'est à dire en fait est-ce que on
arrive à faire les deux ou pas puisque
moi je pense que c'est positif si c'est
pour satisfaire une ambition de
d'innovation et de sécurisation des
produits de santé pour les patients mais
en même temps je suis un petit peu
dubitative parce que le PDG de Pfizer
Albert Bourla disait que c'était un peu
comme la poule aux œufs d'or et là du
coup c'est pas la même chose que vouloir
un développement dans l'intérêt de
l'innovation etc vous voyez il faut
voilà donc on est sur deux c'est une
stratégie qui peut me paraît qui peut
être contradictoire et puis qui peut
conduire au travers
que nous vivons nous aujourd'hui enfin
quand je dis nous il n'y a pas que nous
il y a pas que la France malheureusement
parce que si on était que on pourrait se
dire bon il y a les autres mais là en
France et en Europe
alors il y a plusieurs questions lors de
la question écoutez je
la meilleure façon de répondre à cela
c'est je vais partager avec vous notre
philosophie et notre stratégie comme
société
en aimant partenariat nous avons
découvert qu'on peut pas tout faire
soi-même et je vais retourner ainsi
en 2000 en 2018 on avait signé un accord
de partenariat pour développer un vaccin
contre
la grippe avec biotech deux chercheurs
d'ailleurs d'origine turque qui était
basée à Berlin et qui travaille etc et
on voyait que cette
on va dire que
la reine messager c'est on appelle ça
une plateforme technologique
pouvait quelque part
produire des vaccins avec une efficacité
bien meilleure de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre de
raisons sont rentrées dans le détail
c'était très risqué parce que cette ce
type de de technologie existe depuis les
années 50 dans plusieurs sociétés et
c'est toujours bloqué au laboratoire on
avait travaillé là-dessus on a tout
analysé on a décidé que peut-être
la meilleure stratégie des travailleurs
ce qui s'est passé c'est que juste après
cela il y a eu le Christ de la covid et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on sait on a pris
un risque énorme
financier
légal tout on a pris un risque énorme et
on sait vraiment bon je vais utiliser un
mot assez jeté là-dessus on a dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire quelque part
pour développer très rapidement un
vaccin et nous avons ici en l'espace de
moins de 9 mois si pas parce que c'est
seulement Pfizer ça a été aussi les
autorités de santé alors notre stratégie
a été
d'avancer en parallèle c'est-à-dire
pendant qu'on faisait
l'étude de phase une
en construisait l'usine les inexistaient
mais en l'agrandissait on crée les
lignes on faisait tout en parallèle dès
qu'on avait les données ont commencé la
phase 2 bien sûr en respectant bien sûr
tous les protocoles etc et et les normes
de sécurité alors on avait fait et bon
ça a fonctionné
cet exemple là nous a démontré et
d'ailleurs c'est toujours un partenariat
on n'a pas racheté
un partenariat d'ailleurs ce que je vous
dis officiel quand vous entendez 100
milliards c'est pas exactement 100
milliards c'est que la moitié
automatiquement est versée à biotech qui
va développer d'autres vaccins vous
savez si des accords c'est des contrats
alors nous avons ça c'est notre modèle
c'est de chercher où est-ce qu'il y a le
meilleur savoir-faire les meilleures
technologies
plateformes technologique aussi dans les
maladies rares ok nous avons fait la
même chose avec à Boston une société
dans la thérapie génique
car
quand on a analysé toutes les
plateformes on s'est rendu compte que au
niveau du cancer c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être on espère une des meilleures
stratégies pourquoi parce que ça ça
associe de mécanismes d'action c'est un
anticorps monoclanade chimiothérapie
c'est-à-dire l'anticorps reconnaît la
tumeur et puis elle injecte à la
chimiothérapie cela existe ça existait
même nous dans notre portefeuille nous
avons un produit en hématologie pour ce
type de avec ce type de technologie par
contre on a trouvé que ils étaient très
avancés et que nous avec nos chercheurs
ont prouvé encore aller plus loin parce
que on a des connaissances dans la
synthèse des protéines etc on pouvait
même améliorer cette plateforme c'est
comme ça qu'on a qu'on a fait cet accord
avec Siegen ça c'est pour vous donner
après on est pas encore arrivé où est-ce
qu'on va
produire
actuellement ce n'est qu'un projet c'est
à la fin de l'année où les autorités la
FTC aux États-Unis la Commission
européenne et même en France les
autorités doivent donner le bon vouloir
pour que ça passe
par rapport au covid je vais vous dire
le covid et le vaccin est produit juste
à côté à deux heures de voiture c'est en
à 2h à 3 heures de voiture d'ici c'est
en Belgique
dans
alors
toutes ces nouvelles technologies parce
que vous parlez du passé qu'on a fermé
mais toutes ces nouvelles technologies
notre objectif c'est d'assurer que
l'Europe et j'espère la France
égoïstement j'espère que la France on
puisse ramener ici au moins une étape
parce que ces produits là ont tellement
d'étapes quand vous parlez du du vaccin
contre la covid c'est notre étape quand
vous parlez par exemple du
des produits cigan que je ne connais pas
mais je suis certain que ça sera
plusieurs étapes notre stratégie
s'insérer que les étapes stratégiques
soit quelque part on aura et on espère
bien au moins une étape en France en
bien sûr ça c'est il faut beaucoup de
recherches beaucoup de négociations avec
la maison mère pour cela on ne promet
rien mais ça c'est notre objectif c'est
de ramener ramener le maximum au moins
une étape mais les étapes stratégiques
parce que vous savez il y a des étapes
qu'on appelle
le packaging le packaging l'emballage
merci l'emballage quand vous arrivez
avec l'emballage on vous dit on a
produit en France oui mais c'était le
carton on a mis dedans ça c'est pas ma
seconde on cherche en Europe c'est
surtout
tout ce qui est les étapes stratégiques
ça peut être l'étape des bons quelques
cas des matières premières mais ça peut
être aussi le principe actif ça peut
être aussi comment on mélange comment on
stabilise c'est un nombre d'étapes
incroyable il faut s'assurer que
l'Europe a sa part de marché là-dessus
ça part vraiment là-dedans
c'est ça quelque part notre notre
stratégie c'est partenariat partenariat
partenariat et plus et vous vous avez pu
parler qu'on grossit
écouter
quelque part égoïstement je dis que
oui on grossit en faisant du bien on
fait beaucoup de bien je vais vous
donner un exemple et là je lis devant
moi parce que c'est très important
vous savez nous avons conclu un accord
dans le cadre de l'Initiative covacs
vous avez entendu bien sûr parler de
convexe cet accord a permis la
fourniture à 92 pays bénéficiant de la
garantie du marché convexe de 40
millions de doses de vaccins
anticovid-19 nous distribuons un
milliard de doses par année 1 milliard
de dos parlé c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à
maintenant on a distribué 2 milliards de
doses du vaccin anticoïdes
a des pays avec ce qu'on appelle des
revenus faibles
alors ça c'est un autre point important
ce dont on est très fiers c'est que on
met 2022 notre SIO albarbola a présenté
un accord pour un monde en meilleure
santé c'est à dire que c'est une
initiative
ou on met à disposition de d'une 45 pays
500 médicaments et vaccins à prix
coûtant après coûtant on le met à leur
disposition et ce projet a commencé
l'année passée
ce qui est important c'est pas
uniquement le vaccin ou le produit mais
c'est la vaccination et la thérapie je
m'explique quand on a distribué ce
milliard de doses qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé la plupart n'a pas été utilisée
pourquoi parce qu'il faut accompagner
alors dans ce programme là qui s'appelle
accord
on a construit aussi tout un modèle
d'accompagnement de formation de
professionnelle de santé ça c'est une
chose et la deuxième chose aussi c'est
les aider à monter la structure
l'infrastructure les aider à stocker les
médicaments les former à la vaccination
etc alors on peut faire ça quand on est
gros
vous avez posé la question des outils
mais quand vous parliez d'outils c'était
par exemple lever des brevets ou licence
d'office de ça
peut-être pour vous donner la notre
position parce que on voit bien que
c'est des c'est des outils qui sont
souvent cités maintenant
et l'exemple l'exemple du vaccin était
un quelque chose assez frappant si il y
avait des levés de brevet on aurait la
capacité d'innovation qui serait quand
même
menacé et fragilisé on pense vraiment
que ce serait ce serait très très
délétère que on sait que la protection
et l'application stricte des brevets des
données d'essai réglementaires
constituent des incitations puissantes
justement à investir en R&D donc ça
c'est important je pense de le de le
souligner donc ça c'est notre position
et on voit bien que s'il y s'il y avait
des levées de brevets un il y aurait
plus d'investissement peut-être pour des
futurs pandémies et de ça ne répond pas
à la question parce que les vaccins ils
étaient ils étaient disponibles mais il
y a tout ce qu'il y a après et ça il
faut pouvoir il faut pouvoir il faut
pouvoir l'assurer je pense donc ça c'est
quand même important à garder en tête et
on a mis en place par rapport à
l'antiviral ce qu'on appelle une licence
volontaire donc il y a eu un partenariat
de fait pour justement la permettre à
d'autres de produire cet antiviral donc
il y a tout un tas de choses qui sont
mis en place pour me permettre cet accès
au plus grand nombre mais on est
convaincu que oui lever lever les
brevets
ne répondrait en aucunement à la
question et tu aurais quelque part
l'innovation et je reviens juste sur un
sur un point parce que c'est quand même
aussi important par rapport à la
à la délocalisation comment
je veux pas vous couper c'est votre
votre position donc je la respecte tout
à coup est venu comme un éclair la polio
quand elle est quand en 53 si je me
trompe pas il y avait pas de brevet et
ça a permis de sauver l'humanité donc de
la polio non non mais là moi je vous
donne votre position parce que vous
notre position par rapport aux outils
mais bon
non elle est pas étrange du tout
à fait et non mais peut-être parce qu'à
un moment vous avez abordé aussi le fait
qu'il y ait moins de moins en moins de
sites en France donc je vous dis juste
vous donner l'exemple de notre modèle
effectivement Pfizer avait des sites de
production en France il y a quelques
années on les a on les a cédés à des
façonniers à des façonniers français il
faut savoir que pour la plupart certains
gros médicaments ayant perdu leur brevet
on a eu 60% au moins de production en
moins le fait de les céder à des
façonniers ça a quand même permis un de
maintenir l'activité de maintenir
l'emploi et l'activité parce que un
façonnier bon au début avait aussi les
contrats Pfizer mais avait la
possibilité d'avoir d'autres contrats et
ça je pense que c'est important de le
signaler
alors on en avait exactement 9
donc bon
certains sont devenus indépendants
mais en tout cas voilà ce qui s'est ce
qui s'est passé
ça permet de garder les savoir-faire ça
a permis de maintenir l'emploi bon
maintenant c'était surtout des sites de
production de produits chimiques
et qu'il faut quand même reconnaître que
pendant un certain nombre d'années
la France a perdu en attractivité et en
compétences on pense que ça revient et
on y travaille régulièrement justement
pour ramener tout ça en France
merci beaucoup c'était l'objet de ma
question tout à l'heure justement la
question chimique parce que je
et donc dans les outils il y a la MM
d'urgence aussi qui peut exiger une
levée du brevet en urgence parce qu'il y
a un besoin voilà de sécurité
et d'ailleurs c'est pas ce qu'on a eu
pour les vaccins on a eu une amie
conditionnelle
voilà donc il y a des outils il y a
enfin voilà je vous dis c'est des outils
qui existent mais pour l'instant la
situation c'est pas c'est pas trouver de
le faire mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des
pressions
qui vont dans ce sens aussi voilà
nous l'avons fait pour pas que c'est au
vide vous savez nous avons signé un
accord de licence volontaire
pardon c'est l'antiviral
nous avons signé si je vous rappelle
bien c'était en 2021 un accord de
licence volontaire avec
un organisme MPP
ça c'est une organisation de santé
publique qui est actuellement
soutenu par les Nations Unies et cet
accord de licence
a permis à cet organisme de délivrer des
accords de soul licence à des fabricants
de médicaments génériques dans beaucoup
de pays
beaucoup de pays et on ne bénéficie pas
de cela financièrement
alors il y a toujours un juste milieu
qu'on essaie de trouver
bien écoutez merci beaucoup ce temps
passé de cet échange long et fructueux